We're going to introduce one more list operation that will be
very useful in building our web crawler and that's the
Pop operation. Pop works like this. We have a list.
We have .pop. This is similar to the way we
use the find method. There are no inputs to pop,
but we still need the parenthesis to show that we're
calling a procedure and what it outputs is an element
of the list. What pop does is it mutates the list.
It removes the final element of the list.
It also returns the value of that element. So,
here's an example. If we started by initializing
the variable a to be the list one, two,
three. And then, we'll make b an alias for a, so here's what we have after those
two statements. We have created a new list
with elements one, two, three and a refers to
that list, after the assign a to b statement, b also refers to
that list, then we do x assign
a pop to x. So the value of x will
be three, that's what the last element was. That's what we get returned by pop.
But it also mutates the value of the list. It removes that element. So now a
refers to the list one, two. Since b was an a list for a,
it also changed the value of b. b is now the list one, two.